you're an executive producer on the show
uh yeah yeah on walker and you're also
gonna be the executive producer on the
prequel
yeah so with walker
that was something
[Music]
that
i
kind of i don't say i thought of it
because
you know no one does it alone but that
was something that i was literally in my
trailer i think season 14 of
supernatural uh so the penultimate
season
for a vocab word um
and
i was like i had read some article about
some uh
law enforcement official on the border
it was it was kind of during all the
stuff where
there was uh uh migration kind of into
the states
and people were getting engaged and i
read an article by somebody uh anonymous
like an op-ed um
and they were talking about like they
they ended up in one scenario they're
doing their job uh they're bound by law
and by duty
but they saw like a three-year-old boy
or something and they had a
three-year-old boy and they were like i
can't do this i can't do this anymore
and so they went and and gave their
badge and their gun
to the captain
uh it was like i you know i i may be
court-martialed i may be whatever lose
my pension but i i can't put a
three-year-old in a cage and take him
away from his dad
um and it really
intrigued me
um and so then i was like well what
about like like i want to hear more of
the story you know right and so then
walker was kind of uh that was kind of
the inception
um and then we
we um
we went to anna fricke who
uh is married to jeremy carver who ran
supernatural for a couple years uh and i
knew her
as a friend
um and i was like well is anna available
i feel like she could do the best job
and she was available and she was with
cbs
and she is doing the best job and so it
kind of all fell into place so you were
thinking of doing uh walker it was
already
in motion before supernatural even ended
yeah i mean
it was
it was kind of a funny
sure so
god's honest truth when i was thinking
about walker because i
i i feel like a liar
or i feel like i look like a liar
because i i said this many times during
supernatural and i meant it like i want
to retire man like i don't want to be on
camera again i don't want to do fittings
and have pictures taken to me
um and so i was literally like on the
way out and when i started developing
walker
my pitch
unbeknownst to him
but my pitch was that jensen was gonna
be walker
and i was like well he's in texas like
uh he's a good actor like he likes
riding horses uh so you didn't really
have any id thoughts that i'm going to
do this somebody else is going to do
this
yeah yeah well no no no i i mean i i
thought i was going to do this as far as
like i'll be involved in every script
all the casting right right micro and
micro story lines the tropes this and
that but i didn't want to be on camera i
don't want to be on camera uh
but wait a minute wait a minute hang on
a second i'm a little lost you you're on
the show now and it's season two
and you're the lead but you don't you'd
rather not
act anymore you sort of want to retire
yeah yeah yeah which is which is why it
was kind of a funny conversation with cw
i almost was trying to negotiate myself
out of a deal i was like well um you
know
because mark uh
who you know uh who's an amazing man um
it was like well you know if you want to
come back
into the fold then uh
like
shoot me holler and i was like well you
know i mean frankly i live in austin
it'd have to be in austin he's like i
understand that and i was like okay uh
well you know like i would need to to be
involved creatively not just
saying the words that are written on
page but like directing the storyline
he's like absolutely you've done 400
television like i was like [ __ ] um well
you know i would need like i would need
like a day or two off every episode he
was like of course we want you to be
with your family it's like jesus christ
i can't i can't negotiate myself out of
this deal oh my god
you